brian babin is a republican congressman
from texas and co-chair
of the house border security caucus
congressman thank you
for joining us and i want to go down
your list
what do you want to do with catch and
release
well we want to reinstate reinstate
the not catch of release because this is
exactly what's happened you know i've
been listening to
to your your uh your show here for the
last few minutes
and incredibly jinsaki
at the white house is saying that the
border is is uh is closed it's
far from closed if if it's closed i'd
hate to see what she thinks open is
uh because with all the reversal of the
policies of
president trump's administration by this
uh this administration
it has absolutely created an enormous
uh crisis down there and that's why
we're taking uh
a number of members of the texas uh
house of representatives us house
and we've also i'd like to say this too
arthel we have
we have invited vice president kamala
harris
uh to attend some of our uh itinerary
and see for herself since president uh
biden has given her
uh the direction of the border uh we
thought it would be uh
you know a good thing to do for her to
come down and see exactly what's going
on down there since
in the past she has thought that
president trump's uh
policies were cruel and humane and and
uh and that they were putting children
in cages and quite frankly it's going on
at a much
much worse rate today so a couple of
things congressman i i hear what you're
telling me and i want to i want to
follow up on that what has the vice
president office
told you is the vice president harris
going to
go down with you or what's what's the
plan
we have not heard yet but we're hoping
so
uh we'll be going down there uh tonight
and some of us will be going down there
tomorrow
and quite frankly even president lopez
obrador
has said that that uh that president
biden
is is the is the migrant president he
has created this he wants to turn our
country
in and again i just want to be clear and
how is it what is it so apparently
you've had direct
um you know contact with president
obrador what is he saying specifically
uh in that how president biden is
is causing this give us specifics i'd
like to know sir
you bet well i have not actually spoken
with president obama lopez obrador
uh i have spoken with my colleague
democrat
henry cuellar down in laredo we will be
meeting with him
uh in his district uh when we do the the
tours but there are
there are quotes from president obama
lopez obrador saying that
uh president biden has uh enabled and
and
empowered the cartels and he he actually
called president
uh biden the the migrant president
do you think excuse me but do you think
then to that point
that uh the president of mexico will
want to work with president
biden to reinstate the remain in mexico
policy
i would hope so because it has created
not only chaos in our country
it has created an extremely uh bad
environment for his own and
and i'm going to commend president lopez
obrador because he actually
uh negotiated with our president trump
during his tenure
uh to send his own national guard down
his own
southern border which has absolutely
helped us and if
the bill that you spoke of that i'm
co-sponsoring
what we need to do what president biden
needs to do is to
end catch and release build the wall in
these sanctuary cities
partner up with state and local law
enforcement and
continue the negotiations with president
lopez obrador and restore the remaining
mexico policy
and allow our national guard to go down
there and help defend our homeland by
bolstering
the border patrol's united are keeping
them at
the capitol in washington dc what you're
saying about
your suggestions to secure the border
they all seem to be reasonable so have
you now i asked you about vice president
harris i'm going to ask you about
president biden now have you been
able to get a meeting with him or at
least get some of your delegation to
meet with someone in his office your
people meet with his people in other
words
we have had numbers i'm as you mentioned
i'm the co-chairman of the house border
security caucus we have talked several
times about asking
for meetings with uh with this
administration
uh just like we did during the trump
administration we worked hand in
glove with uh with the administration
that passed
have you gotten a yes to from the bite
administration to your request for
meetings yet
lamentably no we have not just like we
have not heard from vice president
kamala harris but they need to see
exactly what's going on we had our
senators down there
last week and we're going to see the the
same thing but it gets worse
by the day yeah and it is problematic
for sure
absolutely and i want to ask you uh and
i'm asking you these questions because
i i want to just like you we want to
make sure that this gets this problem
gets fixed so when i'm asking you about
the meetings you said you haven't heard
back from them yet
uh did you ju how long ago did you
request the meeting so i'm asking is
that request something that's been
lingering for
60 days or is that something you
requested a couple of a couple of days
ago and you're waiting to hear back from
them
no it's been several days ago we're
waiting to hear back from them
and this we've been we've been told for
for day after day week after week that
this is not a crisis
and yet we know that it is a crisis so
this is time for the administration to
step
up and see it for themselves and not put
unofficial gag orders so the media can't
go down and go in and see these
facilities
and uh and tell us that we have a closed
border and people are being turned back
when we know that is absolutely not the
truth
well there definitely needs to be
transparency the media should be
allowed in so we can show the american
public what's going on
and congressman you seem to have a great
compassion
or passion i should say behind your
fight to secure the border so i'm i'm
hoping
that you will get access to president
biden and to vice president harris in
that somehow
in a bipartisan way we can work to to
fix the problem down there congress
absolutely arthel we have to protect not
only the american citizens and our
national security but protect these
migrants
uh they have been lured up here by
rhetoric from this administration
which has opened this border and
endangers everyone including themselves
congressman brian babin we will leave it
there we thank you for your time this
sunday
thank you arthel take care